[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
brian longing's written confession why
he admits to the murder of fiance gabby
petito and could the accused oxford high
school shooter testify in his parents
coming trial i guess i've been wondering
about that all week whether he's going
to testify something to testify
we're going to call him we need him to
testify plus all that was left of
savannah
was a bag of phones
you're going to hear admissions from
rebecca herself that she
burnt savannah's body
but that is all you're going to hear
because that is all she did hear from
both sides as a missouri woman stands
trial for the murder of her teenage
daughter and later just days after she's
said to be sentenced elaine maxwell is
put on suicide watch in solitary
confinement law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer for the
first time we're getting a look inside
the mind of brian laundry as images of
the notebook containing his murder
confession are released to the public
the laundry family attorney released
photos of the notebook found in a
florida reserve near brian laundry's
remains in the entry laundry admits to
murdering gabby petitto saying quote i
ended her life i thought it was merciful
that it was what she wanted but i see
now all that
mistakes was made
petito was reported missing last fall
while on a cross-country road trip with
fiance brian laundry her body was later
found in grand teton national park her
cause of death was ruled to be
strangulation after a weeks-long manhunt
laundry's remains were discovered in a
florida reserve authorities determined
he died by suicide along with his
remains investigators found a written
confession where laundry admitted to
killing potito in an eight-page notebook
entry laundry writes that petito had
suffered an unknown injury and that he
was trying to help her he writes quote i
panicked i was in shock but from the
moment i decided took away her pain i
knew i couldn't go on without her all
this comes just days after the potato
family appears in a florida court as
part of a civil lawsuit against the
laundries alleging the couple knew gabby
petito was dead before she was reported
missing and helped hide brian laundry
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and long crime legal analyst dina dahl
dina does this end the mystery
surrounding brian laundry and gabby
petito do you have any remaining
questions maybe like what's this unknown
injury that he's talking about
i have actually maybe even more
questions after his notebook because for
one this merciful killing that he's
talking about you know is really not
done if you see somebody in pain and
even if they're suffering usually what
you want to do is go get help um to to
kill them to end their suffering is
really something not very common and
then the way he did it you know you
would think that if she was so weak he
would you know maybe place his hand over
her mouth and
pinch off her nose but instead he
strangles her which is a really violent
act and it's actually an act that is not
so easily defended from right he could
have suffocated if she tried to
suffocate her maybe she could have kind
of knocked away his hand so the kind of
the violent way still by strangulation
and whether or not did he write these
notes after some of these other facts
came out in the news and he's kind of
piecing together a story as a result of
it
to me it does not seem that likely based
on what he said definitely more
questions than answers as we get into
that notebook but terry how does brian's
notebook affect the laundry potato
parents civil suit
you know the real issue in the civil
suit is whether or not there was
intentional infliction of emotional
distress and i don't think that that
notebook is going to make that big a
difference we have to determine whether
or not the defendants acted recklessly
whether or not their behavior was
extreme and whether or not it caused
severe emotional distress the question
is did they know that brian strangled
the daughter and did they know that this
is what he was doing so i'm not really
sure that what was revealed in the
notebook is going to help this
particular civil cause of action yeah
we'll see how it plays out obviously
both sides will use it as to their
advantage or disadvantage as we'll see
it play out well heading now to
minnesota where federal prosecutors
recommend a 25-year prison sentence for
convicted killer derrick chauvin back in
december chauvin pled guilty to federal
charges for violating george floyd's
civil rights just months before the
ex-officer was found guilty on state
charges for floyd's murder floyd's may
2020 death sparked national outrage when
chauvin a white police officer knelt on
floyd a black man's neck for more than
nine minutes floyd's death was ruled a
homicide at the time officers responded
to the scene for reports that floyd was
using counterfeit money body camera
footage shows floyd resisted arrest and
later exclaims i can't breathe as
chauvin knelt on him three other
responding officers to tao thomas lane
and jay alexander king were also charged
and convicted in connection to floyd's
death last week federal prosecutors
recommended a 25-year federal prison
sentence for chauvin followed by five
years of supervised release as of now a
sentencing date has not been set
also in minnesota the city of brooklyn
center reaches a multi-million dollar
agreement with the family of dante
wright a man fatally shot in a 2021
traffic stop by now convicted ex-officer
kim potter it happened on april 11 2021
when potter pulled right over for an
expired tag and an air freshener hanging
from the rear-view mirror as officers
tried to arrest wright on a misdemeanor
warrant he got back in the car there was
a struggle as potter reached for her
firearm she testified at trial she meant
to grab her taser on body camera footage
played for the jurors potter yelled
taser taser taser but pulled her handgun
instead
potter shot right for which she was
charged and convicted of first degree
manslaughter in december two months
later she was sentenced to two years in
prison
the three and
a quarter million dollar settlement is
not final yet because the agreement also
includes changes to police policy which
have not yet been decided changes could
include training on bias de-escalation
and weapons confusion
still ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements are presented as a
missouri woman stands trial for the
murder of her daughter
but first the parents of the accused
oxford school shooter appear in michigan
court could the defense plan on calling
a surprise witness
[Music]
welcome back a michigan judge rules the
coming trial of james and jennifer
crumbly will not be moved out of oakland
county as the couple faces charges in
connection to the deadly oxford high
school shooting
the couple and parents of accused oxford
school shooter appeared in court on
monday that's where judge cheryl
matthews made the ruling also banning
the prosecution from discussing the case
in the media or on the internet judge
matthews also ruled jennifer crumbly's
alleged affair will not be admitted as
evidence nor will the couple's alleged
messy house both jennifer and james
crumbly face charges of involuntary
manslaughter involving the deadly
november 2021 school shooting
prosecutors say their son opened fire in
the school killing four people and
injuring seven others the crumbly
parents are charged for failing to
secure the handgun during monday's
hearing the defense indicated it planned
to call the accused shooter as a witness
in his parents trial
we need him as a witness in this trial
even if he gets up there and he has to
feed the theft he is he can't confuse
that he has a true
you can't please take the benchmark on
the jury well he can he can answer
questions that are not covered by the
fifth environment so we can call him as
a witness and i just
i i was just thinking that if his trial
is scheduled after i suppose he'll still
plead with that so
i can i can see the possibility of how
the defendant's son will be able to
testify in this case
i i don't know i've been
i guess i've been wondering about that
all week whether he's going to testify
something to test time
we're going to call him we we need him
to testify to information not related to
his actual shootings but related to
extraneous matters that are important in
the case
so i guess i'm just as an offer of proof
they want to call their son to
to somehow diminish
highlight his role instead of his
parents i'm just not sure how that's
relevant
they were each calling right but he
can't take the fifth amendment in front
of the jury right so
right so there are certain questions we
would just not be able to ask we do
understand that we we have other
questions we need to ask and
this is not about the defendants wanting
to throw their son under the bus or make
him look bad this is about our clients
defending the case
meanwhile the trial date is delayed by
four months for jennifer and james
crumbly's son the accused shooter the
now 16-year-old will be charged as an
adult on multiple accounts of
first-degree murder and attempted murder
terrorism causing death assault with
intent to murder and possession of a
firearm last week defense attorneys
convinced a michigan judge to delay the
coming trial from september to january
of next year defense attorneys argue
they need more time to go through a
staggering amount of evidence in the
case this comes after a judge ruled all
evidence in the case be released
including surveillance video of the
attack as part of a civil suit brought
by the families of victims the oakland
county prosecutor's office argued
against the move saying it could damage
the cases against the accused school
shooter and his parents as for the state
cases all three crumblies pled not
guilty
all right terry the judge has agreed to
limit pre-trial publicity so what does
that mean for coverage leading up to the
to the trial
clearly brian it's going to make it more
difficult to cover this case but the
sixth amendment does guarantee the
rights of criminals and the fact that it
includes or alleged criminals a public
trial without unnecessary delay the
right to a lawyer the right to an
impartial jury the right to see the
evidence against them i think this judge
is making all of the correct decisions
and what she has to do is weigh all of
those rights against each other and
frankly she has said that this pre-trial
publicity is going to or could in fact
affect a potential jury so i think it's
all the right decisions so far yeah and
and dean i'm curious about this what do
you make of the defense's plan to call
the oxford shooter the defendant's son
as a witness what sort of questions
could or or would they be able to ask
while he's on the stand
i mean it is true that it's going to be
very limited but it makes sense that
they have to because essentially the
charge against him i mean against the
parents have to do with what they knew
about the sun
and what actions they took with regard
to the sun so the sun could help
validate some information about what
kind of parent they were leading up to
this i know there was a lot discussing
about what they did or did not do
regarding his mental health so maybe
discussions around that they'll want to
say and also perhaps conversations or
rules or anything they had about gun
ownership i imagine they're going to
want all of that to come in as well yeah
and i think those are perfect questions
because those sound like they may not
incriminate him for his case but just
kind of separating that nexus between
parents and and son we'll see how it
plays out as it continues though well
coming up on law and crime daily elaine
maxwell is placed on suicide watch just
before she's due to be sentenced plus
opening statements are presented in the
case of rebecca rood a mother accused of
murdering her teenage daughter who had
special needs
[Music]
welcome back opening statements are
presented in the missouri bench trial of
rebecca rood a woman facing murder
charges for the alleged killing of her
16 year old daughter savannah leckie
born to rude was adopted as a baby by a
couple in minnesota tamil and david
leckie rude stayed in savannah's life as
she grew up with the permission from the
adopted parents savannah had autism and
was eventually diagnosed with adhd and
depression during savannah's teenage
years the leckies divorced and savannah
began exhibiting behavioral problems
rude and tamil agreed to have the teen
move to missouri with her birth mother
and her boyfriend robert pete for a
fresh start 11 months later ruud
reported the 16 year old girl missing
authorities say rude abused savannah and
the pair eventually killed her burning
her body in june of 2017. investigators
searched their ozark county farm and
found bone fragments and teeth in a burn
pile there is no jury for rood's trial
as a case is being presented solely
before a judge in their opening
statements monday prosecutors explained
how they believe rude killed her
the daughter drugged savannah with
hydrocodone the defendant thought she
was dead
thought savannah was dead and brought
her body to the burn pile to dispose of
the evidence
and kathy hilton will tell you that the
defendant
admitted to her to throwing savannah's
body in the burn pile
she wasn't dead
she woke up
screaming
and that
during this screaming the defendant hit
her with a rake
or other type of long-handled implement
until she could scream no more
all that was left of savannah
was a bag of bones cruz defense attorney
addressed the judge with her opening
statement saying her client didn't kill
her daughter and that the judge will
hear from rood herself
the defense will present evidence to
show how savannah was hospitalized at
least twice for suicidal ideation due to
self-harm and a plan to commit suicide
you are not going to hear that savannah
was murdered
you will hear no scientific evidence as
to the cause of death
the manner of death or the actual time
of death
you're going to hear admissions from
rebecca herself that she
burnt savannah's body
but that is all you're going to hear
because that is all she did
and we are going to ask at the end of
this trial that you find rebecca not
guilty of counts one two and three
terry bench trial or jury trial it's up
to the defendant usually so why do you
think they're going with a bench trial
in this case this was a very strategic
move on the part of the defense as i
mentioned before under the sixth
amendment you have as a defendant a
right to a jury trial they selected to
have the judge and i think they did that
because this case is so horrific they're
probably gambling that a jury is going
to be too emotional and that the judge
is going to be able to follow the law
and the judge is going to keep them to
that high standard the prosecution of
making sure that it is evidence beyond a
reasonable doubt so i think they
don't believe that a jury can do that
because this is horrible but they do
believe that a judge is going to listen
to the evidence and if anything is
lacking if anything is missing the judge
is going to dismiss the case because it
wasn't proven beyond reasonable doubt
yeah but that's interesting dina because
they have another argument it appears
that robert pete jr the man rude mary
the day her daughter's remains were
found is also charged with her death so
do you think as a part of rue's defense
that she'll be pointing the finger at
her husband
it's it definitely sounds like that and
based on that video we saw it also
sounds like they're going to try to
argue that she killed herself and that
the mother was only disposing of the
remains you know a lot of this will come
down to probably the autopsy report to
show the cause of death if if it was
possible if it was suicidal it certainly
didn't sound like it was the pers uh
prosecutor's description with the rake i
mean this is a horrific crime it's
really hard to hear these details i i
could also see why they would have
wanted a judge to do this but i think
with it being the two of them that's
obviously always a problem with the
prosecution is they can point the finger
at each other and so who actually did it
may be hard to prove
yeah and of course she's been in this
child's life she she adopted the baby
away now got the baby back i think that
might be an argument for the defense to
say why would a mother do this once they
got their child back after so many years
but we'll see how it plays out as this
case continues
when we come back elaine maxwell is set
to be sentenced in federal court could a
recent suicide watch complicate her
sentencing that's a head on on crime
daily
welcome back in washington d.c over the
weekend president joe biden signed into
law the first major federal legislation
on gun safety in decades the legislation
comes on the heels of the most recent
mass shooting in
uvalde texas where 19 elementary school
students and two teachers were killed
and after another shooting at a buffalo
new york grocery store the bill titled
the bipartisan safety communities act
includes millions of dollars to help
states implement crisis intervention
programs including red flag programs
which can temporarily prevent
individuals in crisis from accessing
firearms the bill also aims to fund
programs for mental health and school
safety it also closes the boyfriend
loophole in domestic violence law which
barred some people convicted of domestic
violence crimes from having guns after
legislation passed both the senate and
the house with support from both sides
of the aisle the president signed the
bill on saturday
and just days before geelane maxwell is
set to be sentenced on federal sex
crimes convictions the former socialite
is put on suicide watch
lawn crime network covered maxwell's
federal trial closely where the one-time
companion of jeffrey epstein was
convicted late last year federal
prosecutors say maxwell helped epstein
groom girls as young as 14 years old for
sexual abuse and sometimes participated
in the abuse epstein was arrested on
federal charges of sex trafficking in
2019 but was later found dead by suicide
in his jail cell maxwell's sentencing
date is set for tuesday of this week
where she faces up to 35 years in prison
over the weekend maxwell's attorneys
confirmed she was placed on suicide
watch though they claim she is not
suicidal her attorneys say she was
placed in a solitary confinement last
friday and now argue sentencing should
be delayed because their client cannot
properly prepare
dina what exactly is suicide watch for
an incarcerated person and will that
last for her prison sentence as well
i mean most likely not and they say here
the reason why she was actually put on
suicide watch was because she said she
felt unsafe she wasn't determined
clinically that she was suicidal what
happens there in the well she's on
suicide watch she doesn't have access to
any utensils she doesn't have her
regular clothes or bed linens anything
that can be ripped and used to hang
herself so only heavy-duty smocks and
there's a guard there who watches her
and takes notes in order to determine
you know whether or not she is safe or
suicidal so that was their way of
keeping her safe
um
and but not in solitary confinement
because they were worried that she might
actually go into depression and i think
because of everything what happened with
jeffrey epstein and his suicide they
didn't want that to possibly happen here
yeah i know i know we have medical
rulings that it wasn't suicide but a lot
of people still have that question mark
as to whether or not jeffrey epstein
really took his life so maybe this is
just an additional precaution terry
maxwell's being sentenced on tuesday
what should we be expecting on this
momentous day
i think it's going to be quite emotional
the judge is actually going to decide
what that sentence is going to be she
faces up to 65 years we know the
prosecution is asking for between 30 and
55 years we know that maxwell is going
to ask for much less than that four to
five years and the defense is basically
arguing that because of her difficult
childhood she was more susceptible to
jeffrey epstein so the sentence should
be less because of that she's 61 years
old already no matter what she gets as a
sentence if it's significant it's going
to be as if it were a life sentence
we're going to hear from the victims
also and that's going to be very
impactful yeah we're looking at watch
outs closely as well well thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you